we've got a function y equals etc and
the question says fireman derivative and
thereby substituting a particular value
in this case it's x equals 1 determine
whether the function is increasing
decreasing or station so let's there's
two pieces that let's do one at a time
can you help me out we can work out a
dude you here right now derivative
should be 3x squared fantastic and
finish it off plus five well done okay
excellent
so we have our derivative now please be
cautious in how you do this next part
right this is what we call the gradient
function for any value of x you can find
out the gradient okay but I don't want
any value of x I want a specific one so
you need to actually say what you're
doing right tell me that you're actually
doing a substitution right you could say
at x equals 1 or when x equals 1 but the
key is you're actually telling me what
you're about to do when x equals 1 dy on
DX equals now even though I think you
could probably comfortably do this in
your head I'd like to do the
substitution right so I'm gonna go 3
lots of 1 squared plus 5 three lots of 1
squared is 3 3 plus 5 gives you 8 okay
so we come over to a bit thankfully
thankfully for us the only thing we care
about is what's the sign si GN what's
the sign of the root is a positive is a
zero is it negative in this case
positive right so I would say since dy
on DX is greater than zero right y
that's the name of the function right
that they hand in Australia the top Y is
increasing at that particular place okay
now it's really important that we
mention that Y is increasing at a
particular place because you've got your
computer there now right
I'm pull up there's more sand put this
guy in can you do that for me pull up
there's moss and graph X cubed plus 5x
hmm what's this thing going to uh yeah
the original one it's got a bit of a
wiggle to it doesn't it yeah and they're
both gonna be both me on that side right
okay yes all right who's got it's not
looking for love desmos
hey it's cute post you might need to
zoom out ishani okay it's in fact your
scale that it's gonna exist this 31
is that what you're getting who's gonna
raid oh yeah okay so I think I think
this is what you've got on your graph
there right so what am I saying why is
increasing at a specific spot now before
i graph this I really didn't know what
the rest of the graph looked like rights
right yeah good cover so at a particular
spot right I know it's great it's very
steep by the way the derivative is 8 so
when you got 1 units skyrocketing 8
units okay but this particular example I
just wanted to call out because not only
is it increasing at that particular spot
right it's actually what we call I'm
gonna introduce a new word for you here
it's actually what we call monotonically
increasing when we say someone speaks in
a monotone what does that mean that was
a really good impression serene well
done when we say monotone it's what it
sounds like there's one time to it right
it doesn't change ok now this graph here
is always increasing for any value of x
you put in there it's always going to be
increasing okay how can we know that
have a look at all the working we've
done on the board and on your page
there's actually a piece of working that
tells you that you can reason through
and say oh oh it must always be you can
never turn around and they can never
decrease anyone tell me we have a shot
well what do you think okay so if you
plot zero in here right if we do a
substitution you're gonna get three lakh
to zero plus five zero plus five it's
it's it's five which is why this thing
is still increasing at that point but in
fact we can extend what will said even
you can put in one values in there right
what happens when you put in a negative
three times like say negative 1 what
happens that negative when you square it
it's still positive right so no matter
what should throw into this guy you'll
get a positive value so it is always
increasing and our fancy word for always
in this case is monotonic we're okay so
let me